You know, this is Dr. Kevin Conners and this video is going to go over to some frequently
ask questions that we get at, sometimes at the case review consultation, sometimes we get
it over the telephone, so I want to clear up some things just so you feel settled about
what we do here and how this might fit into your health picture.
So first question that we get a lot is, do you treat cancer?
Well of course we're kids are clinic quote unquote, but the answer is no, we don't treat
cancer and I make that them fanically clear in our by book as well and there's some medical
legal reasons why I say that, but there's some realistic maybe a different understanding
of what we're actually doing to try and take care of our patients.
So from a medical legal standpoint, only your oncologists can treat cancer.
We don't treat cancer in our office.
But I try to cure anybody, we're not treating disease.
We're trying to take care of the patient.
And our belief stems from a core value that the reason why we get sick is that there's
something else going wrong with us and cancer is just an expression of that something
else going wrong with us.
That's why we have those four pillars of care that we're looking for the cause and looking
from a nutritional specialized nutritional standpoint of how we're going to work on that
whole piece.
And then using some instrumentation and some other things that will just help bring it all together
to give you the best opportunity to fight whatever disease that you are diagnosed with.
There's just too many things going on.
We need to look at diet, we need to look at spiritual psychological point of view, different
toxins that have affected you, different drugs that are affected you, your microbiome,
the gut flora that's affected you.
So there's a lot of different pieces to the puzzle that we from an alternative standpoint
take that you're standard oncologist, it literally has to ignore, you have to forgive them
of that.
They are too busy in their system to address these things.
This is not even possible, even if they were educated in this thing.
Let's just be honest, I'm not educated in standard oncology.
So don't ask me whether you should take sysplatted or another chemotherapy.
That is your oncologist's decision and my assistance for you is to look at all the other things
that are going on in your body so that we can clean you up to make you be able to take care
of this disease state as best as you possibly get in.
It will help make your chemotherapy and your radiation or whatever else you are choosing
to do at the same time to work much better and that's really what our goal is.
That's really what integrative care is.
Other question is, why don't you speak of a cure rate?
The reason is because we don't cure anything and I have a big argument with even an oncologist
telling a patient after somebody rounds of chemotherapy and radiation or whatever they're
going to do saying that, great, you are cancer-free.
I think that is a misnomer and you can argue, well that's giving them a sense of optimism,
but the truth is it's just not real.
Nobody that's cancer-free, even if you're not even diagnosed with cancer, you have cancer
cells inside of you, then your immune system is either witty, that battle or it's not
witty, that battle.
That's what's going to give you a diagnosis of cancer or not.
To tell somebody that they're cancer-free is really just dishonest because if you've ever
been diagnosed with cancer, you always have the cancer stem cells or circulating tumor
cells in your body, but that's where these poor individuals, two years later, say, oh my
goodness, it came back with a vengeance.
Well the truth is it never went away.
If you approach it from the standpoint of just being a realist and say, okay, I have cancer,
I'm going to do the things that I need to do to get myself into remission so that this
is no longer a fatal disorder in my life so that now it becomes a manageable problem, that
I'm going to work on my diet and I'm going to work on nutrition and I may choose to do chemo
and radiation and such, but now I'm going to manage it for the rest of my life and hopefully
die of old age in 40 years.
So that's really what our goal is.
Unfortunately, the medical system has manipulated a lot of things and they go by what's called
a five-year survival rate.
Well, that's part of their issue in trying to get early diagnosis of cancer because the five-year
survival rate clock starts at diagnosis so if we could make you live five years, you are
legally, technically, quote unquote, cured.
Well, that's just ridiculous.
You could die a day after five years ticks by and you still are going to go down to the
annuals of their cure rate as a five-year survival, a cured person of cancer and you died a day
after your five-year survival rate.
Well, that's just ridiculous.
That's called manipulation of statistics.
I don't think that's fair to patients.
I don't think that's honest when you're trying to prove that your efficacy of your treatment
by using those numbers, the rubber numbers, and it's just dishonest.
So we don't use anything like that.
Besides the fact that we're not quote unquote, treaty cancer, we're not looking for a cure.
We're trying to get you to survive and to thrive and to live happily and to live without
a ton of side effects of whatever other treatment that you're going through.
That's our goal in your care.
We're coming alongside you, trying to get you to experience this and have it not be such
a horrific experience going through your treatment.
Another question we get is, well, this works so well.
It sounds so good.
How come everybody isn't doing it?
You know, it sounds so great.
Well, there's several reasons for this.
Number one is, it doesn't work so well.
This isn't magic.
So yeah, we have most of our patients that have ever come to see us are still alive today,
but I'm not taking any credit for that.
It's your body healing and it's the other therapies that they did too.
Most of our patients have done chemo radiation and surgery or are doing it at the same time
or whatever.
So we're coming alongside their other care team in order to team up to help them go through
it better.
Well, it seems like this alternative addition to care helps a person live longer.
Well, again, people ask this question, why isn't everyone doing it?
Well, the big reason, I think the biggest reason is fear and partly ignorance, people just
don't know about it.
You're watching this video so you either found it on Facebook or you found it on YouTube
or you're at our website watching this video and you're seeking out some alternative additions
or solutions to your problem and you, that's fantastic, but the majority of people don't.
When you hear cancer in a diagnosis, let's be honest, you're scared stiffless.
And most people get hurted down the standard oncology pathway without really feeling like
they have time because many times they're told they don't, they have to do this right now.
We're starting you with chemo one Monday and we're going to do surgery three weeks later
or whatever the thing is.
You don't really have time to think.
It's hard to digest that big giant word called cancer when you're in a state of panic.
So when you have that terror in your heart, you're not thinking of other things and it's
really easy to put that responsibility on your oncologist to get me better now, instead
of saying, hold on, I'm not giving responsibility to anybody, I'm taking that back and I'm going
to investigate this and think about this and I may choose to do some standards of care,
but I may choose to add or to supplement other things as well so I'll have a better outcome.
So everybody doesn't do it, but I'll tell you right now, it is growing all the time.
This is a 2007 statistic, the 38.3% of adults in the US are using complementary therapies,
not just cancer therapy, but other complementary therapies that's so much lower with children
because legally you can't just rush your children to an alternative cancer clinic without making
sure that you're still following standards of care because legally your children are your
possession, it's your children are the possession of the state. Unfortunately, people don't realize
that until they get into the situation of that, but when we talk about adults, there is a growing
group of people that are seeking an alternative care. We are swummed in our clinic all the
time and it's a great thing and it's great that people are explored other options and I
realize that there's no possible way we can take care of all the people that call us. That's
why we have these videos, that's why we have our website that I'm constantly adding information,
that's why I don't play golf. So I can constantly add information to help people that would never
be able to come to us. So that is our goal, so that I can leave a legacy, that's my desire, to
leave a legacy long after I'm gone, that people can use this information to help them or their loved
ones. So people are using it and it is a giant growing trend. Another big question, people don't think
that they can add complementary alternative therapy to their standard approach and that is horrible
because when you add complementary therapy, the therapies that you'll see on this website, two
standard ecological procedures, you're going to go through those standard procedures much better in
my opinion and that's based upon by experience. People that are doing alternative therapies while they're
doing standard ecological therapies go through those much smoother. We could support your liver detox
pathways and we could do a genetic test to find out how your liver detox pathways need support
and then support those pathways. You're going to be able to go through chemotherapy and radiation much
more successful. If you're using a rife machine, that can help even target your chemotherapy. So
that is so much more effective, you're going to get better benefits out of it. So absolutely you can
add this to your standard of care. That's really what integrative cancer care is. Integrative cancer
care is that you have multiple helpers through your problem. I think one of the greatest mistakes any
person could make with their health care is to take a dogmatic approach and I said this 100 times
before. But you take a dogmatic position in anything. Your mind is made up. You've already made your
decision. It's done. I'm going to follow exactly what my oncologist says and that's all I'm going to do.
I'm never going to go to an alternative doctor. Well, you're going to have a limited success. But I
also think you can be dogmatic the other way. No way. I've never gone to an oncologist. I'm only going
to go to an alternative doctor. I'm never going to do surgery chemo or radiation. I think that is
equally as foolish. You need to have, you know, the Bible is very clear. There's a wisdom in a
multitude of counselors. You need a lot of people to be adding to your piece of puzzle and it doesn't
mean you necessarily choose not to do an integrated approach. That's fine. Or you choose not to do
standards of care. That's fine. But you have to be open to it and investigate it. And obviously you're
watching this video. So that's the position you're at. Another question is when is the best time
to start alternative methods? We get this a lot. People on the phone would be saying, well, I
photo and I have cancer. I guess I really want to do this. This meeting, you know, an alternative
approach. But I get a way till I finish chemo. That's fine. You know, but I'm just telling you my
opinion, the alternative approaches will help you go through chemo much better. It will help target
chemo. It will help pull it out of your body. It will have less side effects. So the best time to start
ultimately has got to be your decision when you're going to start. But really the best time to start
an alternative approach is immediately. Does it take the place necessarily of standards of care?
But it's going to really help you go through that much better. So ultimately our desire is that you
see God's will and what you should do. Don't be afraid. If you're a believer, make sure that you
get under these and pray it. And then just listen and just be quiet and listen and say, God,
you know my heart. I don't want to have cancer. But you've allowed this in my life for some reason.
I don't know why people ask me this question all the time. If you got cancer, would you do chemotherapy?
And the answer is, well, God knows me. He made me. He created me. He knows I don't want to do chemotherapy.
So that would be my prayer. Lord, you know, I do not want to do chemotherapy. But please change my
heart. If this is the the path you want me to go. And so it may be with you. Maybe you're more
afraid of alternative therapies. We'll get on your knees and say, Lord, what should I do? And we
certainly don't want people coming to us because they're just scared, spittless, and they don't have any
other options. We want people coming to us because they feel glad because they feel like they're walking
in wisdom because they feel like they sought out answers and they spend time investigating and they
wait out their decisions. Should I do this or should I do this? Well, this has this advantage,
and this has the other advantage. And here's some disadvantages and here's some positives.
Lay it out. Get out a piece of paper and draw the pros and cons of your decision-making process.
Always, I beg you to understand you have more time to make your decision than anybody else tells you to.
Don't let me. Don't let your own colleges. Don't let somebody else scare you into making
a decision based upon fear. That's your that's the worst mistake you could possibly make. Probably one
of the the most common comments I receive from a patient is the comment that I wish I would have
blank. Maybe I wish I would have waited to start chemo where I wish I would have investigated
this first. I wish I would have whatever it is. You do not want to live your life with regrets.
That's number one. So spend time. Slow down. Put the brakes on. I know you're scared. You're fearful.
You don't know what to do. My biggest piece of opinion to you is just to put the brakes on and ask God,
what am I supposed to do? Yes, maybe you're not going to hear this audible voice in the heavens part.
But you'll know in the depth of your hearts and you'll have a piece that passes all understanding
of what you ask Him for wisdom. He's promised to give it to you. So do that. And just just slow down
and ask Him. That would be my biggest request from from everybody. Art as I hear is to give you as
personalized medicine as possible. That's what art as I hear as I hope. This little frequently
asked question video helps you read the rest of the frequently asked question things that are
typed out on this page as well. If you're not at the page, you're just watching the video on Facebook
or something like that. Go to our website cutters clinic and you'll find a whole bunch of information
and above all spend a lot of time on our website getting as much information as possible. So it helps you
weigh out your decision. Alright, thank you so much. Know that we'll be praying for you. Bye-bye.